Hi my name is Sydeaka Watson.
And so that's me.
I work as a data
scientist at Eli Lilly,
the pharmaceutical company.
I'm on the development team
for a Shiny application
that is used at Lilly.
So essentially my job is to
wear this hat, the app developer
hat.
And this isn't just
the normal Shiny app.
This is a complex
production-grade app.
We get a new version of the
app released every month
with new features and
bug fixes, and a lot
of people in my organization
visit this app every day,
so it's really important that
the app is functioning properly
all the time.
So with that in mind,
I'd like to begin
with a story about something
that happened to me back in May
2021.
So I was in my
home office working
on a new feature for the app.
But of course I was
multitasking because I was also
keeping an eye on the activity
in our team chat window.
So one of the users was
saying she was having
some issues with the app.
It wasn't populating the
dropdown menu with the values
that she was expecting.
So the values were in the app
before and then all of a sudden
she didn't see them anymore.
So one of the other developers
identified the issue
and determined that we would
have to quickly release
a new version of the
app that resolved
the issue with
the dropdown menu.
And that's when I
panicked because I
realized that meant two
things were about to happen.
First it meant.
First it meant that I would have
to put on another hat, my code
reviewer hat.
So as a code reviewer, I'm
responsible for reviewing
GitHub pull requests. I have
to read the code to make sure
it adheres to our
coding standards.
And then I have to run the
app in a local environment
to make sure that all
the old features work
with the new features.
I have to check the radio
buttons, the dropdown menus,
the contents of the tables.
I have to make sure that the
database API and the model API
connections are still working
as they used to, right,
as we added these new features.
And so if it passes those
tests, then we deploy the app
to the test server.
But then that means I have to
put on yet another hat, right?
This time I have to put
on my app tester hat.
So as a member of
the app testing team,
I was one of several people
that had to manually deploy
the deploy, the deploy.
I had to manually test the
deployed version of the app.
So I would have to open
the app in a web browser
and then run a lot of
the same tests as before.
Check the radio buttons,
check the dropdown menus,
check the API connections,
database connections,
all those other things that I
did before in the code review.
And so now the
only difference is
that this is on the
deployed version of the app
as opposed to the pre
deployment version.
Now testing is very important.
It does allow us to catch
bugs so that we can fix them
before the new version of the
app is released to production.
However, as one of the
people that had to,
you know, who was responsible
for actually running the tests,
I could say that this was
a really extremely tedious,
painful experience for me.
It was very stressful.
I also felt under-valued, right?
Because I'm thinking, OK,
I have a PhD in statistics
and yet my job now is to click
this radio button, right?
Or check this dropdown menu.
So I felt like this wasn't
a good use of my time.
Another issue is that I
and the other app testers
had other priorities, so we
weren't full time app testers.
We could only run
the tests when we
had time to squeeze testing in.
And that meant that managing
all of those testing
those schedules across the
different testers meant that it
could take a long time for
us to get through those tests
and actually go to the next
stage of our software release.
So because so that was
increasing the amount of time
it took us to deploy the app.
Because it was so
time intensive,
we had to sparingly
apply these tests.
So we couldn't
afford to run them
as new features were
coming in, we had to
or use multiple scenarios.
We can only do them really once,
you know, if we could do that.
And then lastly, we found
that different testers
were running the tests with
different conditions, slightly
different conditions.
So there was some subjective
assessment with whether or not
the tests passed or failed.
So one tester
could say it passed
and another person
running the same test
would say that it failed.
So that was a problem.
So because these releases were
such a heavy burden for me,
I started looking
for a way to make
this process more efficient
for me and for our team.
I was already familiar
with Selenium.
I knew it was a great tool
for automating interactions
with a web browser,
and I figured
this might help automatically
check whether the UI
elements were still working
on the deployed version
of the app.
I was somewhat familiar
with the rvest package
and that it was great
for web scraping,
so I figured this might help
to programmatically extract
the contents of
the web page and I
could run some sanity
checks against it
to make sure everything's
rendering properly. So Selenium
and our rvest could work
together on the deployed version
of the app.
My colleague Eric
Nantz recommended
that I use the
shinytest package
to test the code that other
developers were submitting
in their pull requests.
So he figured that
might help to automate
some of the code reviews.
And then, of course,
later I found out
that there was another version
of the shinytest package
called shinytest2
that somebody
will speak about later.
And then finally, the
shinytest documentation
was recommending that we also
use the testthat package.
And so now I had
all these tools. There
was a bit of a
learning curve, but I
took about three
months of my time
and eventually over
the next three months,
I was able to use those tools
to create an automated testing
pipeline.
Let's see how the software
release workflow changed
after introducing these tools.
So in the code
review stage in blue,
we see the manual pre-deployment
testing during code reviews
was replaced with the
shinytest2 script that
automates these same tasks.
And now the code
reviewer hat sits
on the head of the bot
that runs the test script.
And then in orange, in the
post deployment testing stage,
I'm running the manual tests,
the manual regression tests,
I'm replacing those with the
suite of Selenium test scripts.
And then I get to remove
that heavy app tester
hat from my head and
place it on the bot who
is happy to run
those test scripts.
At least he doesn't complain
about it if he does not
feel happy about it.
So those two changes
had a significant impact
on our software
release workflow.
Our code reviewers and app
testers had less work to do.
They weren't feeling stressed
out with each new release.
We didn't have to worry about
testers balancing their testing
duties with other
high priority work.
So we ended up shortening
our time to deployment
from five days to five hours,
which was pretty, pretty
huge for our testing team.
We could apply our testing
criteria as often as needed.
So no matter how
many releases we
had during the month
or a feature feature
pull request that we
merged during the month
And then because
the test logic was
contained in the test script,
that meant we could
consistently apply those
that test logic from
one test to one,
from one test run to the next.
So that removed that
variation in test results
that we were looking for.
I've talked about this before
on the previous slides,
but here's where I get
to formally introduce
the automated testing
pipeline that I'm proposing.
It contains four key principles.
First, I believe you should
automate the tests, right?
You should actually
have some sort
of programmatic representation
of your test logic.
And this could obviously
be we could easily
fill an hour or maybe a
day talking about this,
but lots of different
things like,
you know, how do you
recover safely from errors?
How do you appropriately
log the test results?
How do you have this repository
of all your test artifacts,
maybe your screenshots
or things that
were downloaded in the
course of running the app?
You know, that's what
I mean by automating
the test. So all of that.
Next, it's important to have
one or more development servers
that are completely separate
from your production server,
and that allows us to see
how the updated app works
without breaking the production
version that end users are
interacting with.
And then the next
two principles have
to do with when we
would run the test.
The first is that I
recommend running the tests,
running some
pre-deployment tests,
so that you can integrate
these features safely,
you know, in a safe space
on your development server
without crashing the
version of your app
that the end users are using.
And then finally,
I would recommend
running the
post-deployment check also
on the development server.
And this is where
we can more closely
mimic what the end
users are going
to experience when they log into
the app using the web browser.
So again, pre deployment
and post deployment
that that's really important.
One question that comes
up is whether automation
makes sense for a particular use
case or a particular web app.
And to answer this question,
I usually follow up
with a couple of
follow-up questions.
The first would be, is
the logic consistent?
The test logic, is
it consistent, you
know, from one run to the next?
So if you can say your step
one, step two, step three,
if you can actually
have all of that logic
and not have to worry about it
changing from one to the next,
that's one consideration.
And then the second
question would
be whether the test logic
can be completely scripted
so that you can get the
result without having
to use any sort of
subjective judgment
or having some sort of human
involved making that decision.
There are other
considerations, obviously.
So there's, do you have
the infrastructure
to support these automation
tools like shinytest2
or Selenium?
Do you have time
to do this, right?
There's a little bit of a
learning curve and a little bit
of time investment and in terms
of writing these test scripts.
But in general, I would
say if you answered Yes
to both of those
questions, then I
would say your app is a prime
candidate for automation.
So I prepared a working example
that you can play around
with on your own.
It's a simple app that allows
you to create an ice cream
recipe using various ingredients
like peanuts and raisins,
and chocolate syrup.
And for the adventurous, if
you want to add some chicken
nuggets to your ice
cream, no judgment here,
but we allow you to do that.
So the GitHub repo, the GitHub
repo linked at the bottom
has all the code
needed to run the app.
It also has the shinytest2
and the Selenium code
that will allow you to
just play around with this
in your own environment.
So I definitely encourage
you to check it out.
I created a couple of screen
casts that demonstrate
how this would work.
So first I'll show
you the pre deployment
testing with shinytest2.
Now if you're running the
shinytest script in the RStudio IDE,
I'll pause this. First, you'll
see that there's a run test
button visible at the
top of the script,
and if you click that,
you'll see that there's
some activity
happening over here
in the Build tab that shows
the progress of the test run.
This test script
automatically opens up
this local version of the
app in a web browser window.
So I didn't do that.
It did it on its own
in Google Chrome.
And then you'll notice that it's
selecting various checkboxes
and entering text
in the text field
and doing all kinds of things,
and showing how the
app is changing.
So all of those things
happened automatically.
And so when I go back
to the RStudio IDE,
I see that the
test result folder.
Now contains a few files that
were saved in the test run.
And if I click on
one of those, I've
got some screenshots
that show, you know,
what the app looked like at
various points in the app.
There's also this
JSON file that shows
the values of various
elements in the UI
as they were at the time that
the snapshot was created.
If you stick around for the
next talk in this session,
you'll actually get a
chance to see the package
author of, you know, the
shinytest2, a developer
give a presentation
about shinytest2.
So I didn't spend a whole
lot of time thinking
about that for
this presentation,
but I highly recommend
that you check that out.
And now finally,
I'll show you what
the post-deployment
version of the testing
looks like with Selenium.
So as before, we click the
Run Test button at the top,
we will also see the test
run progress in the Build tab
in the upper right corner.
Now, before we would actually
open up automatically this web
browser in Google Chrome, but
this is a headless browser,
so we don't actually have
access to that browser.
Instead, it's just going
to do it under the hood
and silently execute those test
instructions that I provided.
And so we'll just see the.
We'll see the mouse that I can't
see anymore for some reason.
Where are you, mouse?
I see it on your side, but
not my side for some reason.
Let me mouse.
OK there we go.
OK, I'll pause that here.
So what you saw and
unfortunately, I
wasn't able to narrate that
while it was going while I was
looking for my mouse, was
that it was showing you
how it was actually
programmatically running
the script.
And then it captured some
screenshots along the way
as it progressed through
the various test scripts
and it also in the log
area, it let you know
what was going on in the app.
So at this point
it was selecting
the flavor, and another point it
was selecting the recipe name,
and so on.
So this was all very
easy and straightforward
thanks to the tools
that, you know,
some of the other
developers have created.
So I thank them for that.
So in closing, I'd
like to reemphasize
that these tools really
make automated testing more
accessible to the general
population of data
scientists, especially
people like me,
who don't have any formal
training in software
engineering or software testing.
Right? We're kind of
expected to know a lot
and do a lot about a
lot of different areas.
But this makes that a
lot easier for us to do.
And then another thing that
is out of scope for this talk,
but I get asked
this all the time
when I give a presentation
about automated testing,
you know, how does this fit
into the CI/CD pipeline?
You know, it definitely does.
And there's lots of tools
that you can use to do that.
In particular, for example,
if you had GitHub Actions,
you could programmatically run.
So as a person submits
their pull request,
you could programmatically
run your tests
on the pre-deployment
version of the app,
merge the pull requests,
deploy to the next test server,
and then actually
programmatically run
that next set of scripts.
Right? So you can do
a lot of these things
made very, very easy.
So I'd like to
thank my colleagues
at Eli Lilly in the Design
Hub Data Insights, Information
and Digital Solutions, and
Statistical Innovation Center
teams for their help.
And I'd also like to
Thank Wardell Picquet
at Picquet Studios for his
help with the graphic design
in my presentation.
And here's my
contact information.
Feel free to reach out if
you'd like to discuss anything.
And I thank you for your time.